Musique douce à la guitare
La musique s'intensifie en rock.
...
Musique dynamique
-Bonjour et bienvenue
dans votre magazine
de l'éducation.
Chaque mois, nous partons
à la rencontre de ceux
qui font l'école
pour vous faire découvrir
leurs méthodes
et leurs initiatives.
Vous allez tout savoir grâce
à "Liberté égalité scolarité",
et voici le sommaire.
-Que se passe-t-il en France
avec les mathématiques ?
Manque de vocation,
mauvais classement international...
On s'est intéressé à ces profs
qui s'ingénient à donner aux élèves
le goût
de l'algèbre et de la géométrie.
Lui, les maths
n'ont aucun secret pour lui.
Hugo Duminil-Copin a obtenu
la médaille Fields en 2022,
mais était-il
le roi des maths à l'école
et quelle est sa recette
pour faire aimer la matière ?
Il nous dit tout
dans Mémoires d'école.
Que font les élèves
pendant les temps
d'activité périscolaire ?
Réponse avec le REV,
le responsable éducatif ville,
qui officie
dans des écoles primaires.
REV, TAP,
des acronymes
qui, après cette émission,
n'auront plus de secret.
Enfin, comment le cinéma
est-il entré à l'école ?
C'est notre retour en archives.
Musique dynamique
...
La France est-elle
fâchée avec les mathématiques ?
Nous figurons
parmi les mauvais élèves
des classements internationaux
et notre niveau a baissé
depuis 40 ans.
Comment nous réconcilier
avec les maths,
les faire aimer aux élèves ?
Au collège Jacques-Yves Cousteau,
A Bussy-Saint-Georges,
depuis deux ans,
l'équipe pédagogique
mise sur l'aspect ludique, pratique,
mais est-ce que ça marche ?
-Bonjour.
Bonjour, bonjour.
-Bonjour !
Musique dynamique
-Allez, hop.
-Je peux en prendre une ?
Vous en avez assez ?
-Oui, normalement.
On a pris une brique comme celle-là.
Je l'ai ouverte
pour voir quelle est la partie
du papier qui est utilisée.
Cette brique,
on s'est demandé
si cette surface était
la plus petite possible
qui pouvait donner un volume
de un litre, c'était le cylindre,
et on a étudié
le cylindre.
Allez, si je prends
un cylindre...
J'ai une certaine hauteur,
qui est H.
J'ai deux bases
qui sont des disques,
et le rayon, on va l'appeler R.
C'est le rayon R.
-Je peux m'asseoir ?
-Pas de souci.
-Que travaillez-vous comme notions ?
Au tableau, on est
sur des formules,
de la géométrie, aussi,
le calcul des surfaces.
-Et du calcul littéral, aussi.
-D'accord.
Dis-moi.
-Souvent,
on va chercher l'aire,
et ensuite,
le volume qu'on peut contenir.
-Donc un litre de lait
dans une brique
peut être aussi contenu
dans un cylindre,
mais ça utilise...
-Moins d'espace.
-Moins de carton.
Ca a un impact écologique.
-Oui.
C'est pour utiliser
le moins d'arbres,
pour essayer de pas trop
polluer la planète.
Monsieur Mesmoudi,
expliquez-moi un peu.
Sur les trois heures et demi
de cours de mathématiques
que vous dispensez
aux troisièmes,
est-ce que ces trois heures et demi
sont toutes axées
sur le développement durable
et l'écologie,
ou c'est une heure dans la semaine,
et le reste du temps,
c'est des maths plus classiques ?
-Pour intéresser les élèves,
il faut varier les supports
et les méthodes.
Il faut rendre
les mathématiques vivantes.
Donc on s'intéresse
aux problèmes de tous les jours.
Musique dynamique
...
Calculez, on remplace X.
Au lieu de remplacer par 0,5,
tu vas remplacer X par ça
et tu calcules.
Bravo.
Vous finissez le travail
pour la semaine prochaine.
-AU REVOIR.
-A la semaine prochaine.
...
-Bonjour, Valérie, bienvenue.
-Merci de nous accueillir
dans ce collège qui a
cette spécificité
de mettre un peu les mathématiques
au coeur, j'ai l'impression,
de l'établissement,
de votre envie,
en tout cas, de les rendre
plus ludiques, plus simples.
Est-ce que je me trompe ?
-Pas du tout.
On a vraiment un plan global
mathématiques.
L'idée, c'était de se dire :
"Comment je peux aborder
les maths autrement,
"faire en sorte que les élèves
"qui sont les plus en difficulté
ne soient pas dans un sentiment
"de 'j'aime pas les maths'
pour toute la vie,
"ou 'c'est moi contre les maths' ?"
-"Et c'est pas fait pour moi."
-Oui.
Et au contraire,
d'avoir des leviers
qui permettent peut-être
d'aller chercher
des vocations,
aussi bien universitaires,
avec des études supérieures
destinées aux sciences,
mais ça peut être aussi
sur des mathématiques
plus appliquées
vers la voie professionnelle.
-Quel résultat ?
-On n'a pas forcément
une élévation numérique
pour les élèves
les plus en difficulté,
mais par contre,
et je reprendrais un des thèmes
qui pour nous est important,
l'estime de soi,
le bien-être.
...
-Okay, very good afternoon,
every one.
Okay, how are you, today ?
In a good shape ?
-YES.
-Okay, good.
I will give you the documents
we're gonna study together today.
-Thank you.
Cette fois-ci, cours de maths,
mais en anglais.
-Okay, we have the base,
three meters long.
-And we need...
-To find the hypotenuse.
All right ?
-How can we proceed
to get the result ?
Propos inaudibles
Yeah, Pythagore's theorem.
-Are there other words
that you do not understand ?
Rémy ?
-"Un bateau à voile".
-Sails, yes, absolutly.
"Propelled,"
it's pretty close to French...
-Ah, "propulser" ?
-Absolutly.
-Vous faites
l'intégralité du cours
de maths en anglais.
Comment est né ce projet ?
-On a commencé
à en discuter l'année dernière
avec monsieur Mesmoudi,
avec l'idée de décloisonner
un petit peu les matières.
Ca pourra leur servir
pour la suite,
parce que ça leur donne
l'idée qu'ils peuvent
suivre un cours
dans une autre langue.
-Pour quel résultat ?
Qu'est-ce que vous percevez ?
-Nous, ce qu'on a perçu,
c'est à la fin du premier cours
qu'on a donné à cette classe,
de l'entrain de la part des élèves,
de la motivation.
-You have closed the rope
and you want to make
a right-triangle.
So you have to take juste three...
Three, four...
Triangle, you see ?
...
-Il y a les cours de maths imposés
dans les emplois du temps
et pour ceux qui le souhaitent,
il y a un club de maths.
...
-Tu prends ce bloc-là...
-OK, du coup, il faut que je...
-Donc ajouter,
je sais pas ce que t'avais choisi.
-Moins 5.
-Voilà.
Il faut aller
dans "capteur".
-C'est...
-Voilà, c'est ça, tu le mets là.
Voilà, c'est ça.
-En quoi consiste ce club de maths ?
-Déjà, en premier lieu,
à s'amuser en faisant des maths.
L'objectif, c'est de programmer.
Donc programmer des jeux vidéo,
et sans s'en rendre compte,
on fait des maths.
Il y a pas besoin
d'être bon en maths.
On programme sans être bon en maths,
mais on programme,
et on peut en même temps
aller plus loin.
...
-Salut !
-BONJOUR.
-Qu'est-ce que vous avez créé ?
-On a créé un jeu "Dragon Ball Z".
-OK, un jeu "Dragon Ball Z !"
Et comment vous avez fait
pour le créer ?
-D'abord, on s'est basés
sur les déplacements rapides.
-OK.
-Pour que ça soit réaliste.
-D'accord.
-Après, on s'est basés
sur les petites attaques,
par exemple, corps-à-corps.
-OK !
Donc ils peuvent donner
des coups de poing comme ça ?
-Oui.
-Et quoi d'autre ?
Waouh !
Pour créer ça,
vous avez fait des maths ?
Il fallait faire des maths ?
-Là, c'est X,
c'est le milieu, le centre.
-OK.
-Là, c'est Y.
Là, si on ajoute 10 à Y,
ça monte, la flèche du haut.
Quand on met moins, ça descend,
et c'est pareil pour...
-Donc c'est comme si
on avait un plan
avec une abscisse ordonnée.
-Oui.
Musique dynamique
...
-Est-ce qu'on vous dit :
"Je veux devenir créateur
de jeux vidéo ?"
-J'ai eu des élèves,
ces dernières années,
qui voulaient être développeurs,
par exemple créer des sites web.
Oui, être programmeurs, quoi.
...
Musique rock dynamique
-Lui relève très largement
notre niveau national
en mathématiques.
Hugo Duminil-Copin a reçu
en 2022 la médaille Fields,
l'équivalent du Prix Nobel,
en mathématiques.
Etait-il un génie
dès la maternelle ?
A-t-il une idée bien à lui
pour intéresser
les élèves
à sa discipline ?
Bonjour, Hugo Duminil-Copin.
-Bonjour.
-Merci d'accepter de répondre
à nos petites questions.
-Avec plaisir.
-Est-ce que vous êtes né
avec la bosse des maths ?
-Non, clairement pas.
Je viens d'une famille
d'enseignants.
Mon père était prof de sport,
ma mère, danseuse,
puis est devenue enseignante,
institutrice.
Les mathématiques
faisaient pas partie
de notre vie, enfant.
-Quel type d'élève vous étiez ?
Petit, à l'école primaire.
-J'avais la chance d'être
quelqu'un qui avait des facilités
mais qui m'ennuyait...
pas vraiment.
J'avais pas ce problème d'ennui
parce que j'avais toujours envie
de maîtriser un peu plus.
J'avais ce côté-là
dans toutes les disciplines,
avec des réussites, on va dire,
qui variaient en fonction
des disciplines.
Les langues, par exemple...
-C'est pas votre truc ?
-Ouh là là, c'était...
Enfin, ça l'est toujours pas,
mais c'était très dur.
Il y avait pas un succès absolu,
mais j'étais
plutôt en réussite,
et j'avais pas le problème
du premier de la classe
parce que j'aimais énormément
le sport, j'avais plein d'amis,
donc j'ai vécu
une enfance à l'école
très facile, je dirais.
J'ai pas eu de grosses difficultés.
-Comme au collège et au lycée ?
-C'est vrai que le lycée Louis Grand
a été un choc parce que je me suis
retrouvé en première en difficulté
en mathématiques,
contrairement à avant.
-Vous avez des photos...
-Oui.
-...de cette époque.
On est en quelle clase ?
-En première,
dans une classe
spéciale à Louis Grand,
avec les gens les plus à l'aise
en sciences.
Et donc là, premier examen
de l'année.
Je fais, je sais plus,
avant ou avant-dernier en maths.
"Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?"
Et ça m'a demandé un énorme travail,
justement, pour récupérer
de ce niveau.
-Vous vous en souvenez.
Ca a marqué votre scolarité ?
-C'est fondateur,
et je pense que c'est aussi
quelque chose qui m'aide énormément
dans mon travail de chercheur,
c'est que ça a été un échec,
mais constructif.
-OK.
-Ca m'a fait me rendre compte
de certaines limites,
en particulier, peut-être,
jusque-là, j'avais cette idée
que les mathématiques
étaient innées.
J'étais jeune et bête.
Ou naïf, je dirais, plutôt.
Et là, je me rends compte
qu'il faut travailler.
-Les maths, c'est pas inné ?
-Pas du tout.
C'est quelque chose
qui s'apprend,
qui se développe
comme n'importe quelle autre qualité
chez l'individu
et il faut casser
ce message qui, je trouve,
est extrêmement inhibant, de dire :
"Soit c'est déjà fait soit...
"Soit vous l'avez,
soit vous l'avez pas."
-Aujourd'hui, on le sait,
classement PISA assez terrible.
Les élèves français se classent
régulièrement parmi les moins bons.
Qu'imaginez-vous comme solution ?
-Faire des travaux pratiques
de maths, par exemple.
Pourquoi il y en a de physique,
de biologie, de chimie ?
C'est implémenté
par les enseignants,
mais qui sont parfois
un peu obligés
de faire chacun
comme ils peuvent.
Ce qui est clair,
c'est qu'il y a
un travail à faire sur la vision
des maths et des sciences
à la fois à l'école
et hors de l'école.
Ca prend en compte les élèves,
les enseignants,
les parents d'élèves,
les décideurs politiques.
Il y a un moment
où il faut qu'on se repose
la question
de ce qu'on souhaite
pour la science
et comment on va se baser
sur le progrès scientifique.
-Merci beaucoup.
-Merci.
Musique dynamique
...
Au gré des réformes
sur les rythmes scolaires,
la Ville de Paris
a décidé de conserver
la semaine de 5 jours
et propose aux élèves
des TAP,
des temps d'activités
périscolaires,
en plus des 24 heures
d'enseignement hebdomadaire.
De la pause méridienne
à l'étude du soir,
tous les temps
en dehors de la classe
sont pensés et orchestrés
par le REV,
le responsable éducatif ville.
Nous sommes devant l'école primaire
du Château des Rentiers,
dans le 13e arrondissement.
On va se glisser
dans une journée de REV.
Elle frappe à la porte.
-Entrez !
-Bonjour, M. Falzon !
-Bonjour !
Vous allez bien ?
-Très bien, et vous ?
-Super.
-Vous êtes le REV
de cette école,
donc le responsable
éducatif ville.
La journée commence par quoi ?
-Par un bilan
de la journée :
absences, remplacements,
et je fais un point sur le logiciel
de présence des animateurs
pour organiser le service
pour que ça se passe au mieux.
-La spécificité
dans toutes les écoles parisiennes,
ce sont les temps
d'activités périscolaires.
-Oui. On a des TAP
le mardi et le vendredi,
qui sont optionnels
et financés par la mairie de Paris.
-C'est gratuit pour les parents,
et c'est 1h30 le mardi
et 1h30 le vendredi.
-Oui. C'était une idée
à l'aménagement
du rythme éducatif en 2013.
-Coucou !
-Salut, ça va ?
-Ca va, et toi ?
-Ouais, ça va.
-Hola !
-Salut !
Aujourd'hui, il y a
plusieurs absences.
On va s'organiser avec Laura.
On va y aller tout de suite,
les enfants sont en train de sortir.
...
-Pendant le premier service,
il y a donc des enfants
qui attendent le deuxième service,
et vous proposez
à ces élèves-là
plusieurs activités.
Ils peuvent avoir
un petit temps de détente,
ou alors...
-Sinon, il y a
la ludothèque dans l'école.
Je vais vous montrer.
-Allez.
...
Bonjour !
-Bonjour.
Bonjour, les enfants !
-Là, les filles sont en train
de jouer au labyrinthe magique,
où chaque personnage
a une petite bille
aimantée en dessous,
et on peut déplacer
le personnage
avec un dé. Vas-y.
Elle lance le dé.
-Vous venez toujours
à la ludothèque
avant la cantine ?
-OUI.
-Souvent.
...
-Là, on a les animatrices
qui sont en train
de répéter un flash mob.
*Musique énergique
-A droite !
*...
Les enfants crient.
...
-Génial ! Bravo !
-Bravo !
-Et là ?
-Là, c'est la passation.
13h20 :
on ramène les classes
dans leur classe.
-Allez, vous rentrez
dans la classe.
Musique douce
...
-Là, Régis, il est 15h.
C'est la première activité
qu'on va suivre.
C'est quoi ?
-C'est un atelier webradio.
Une association
intervient sur l'école.
Donc là, on va
dans un centre qui propose
un vrai studio de radio dans lequel
les enfants vont pouvoir s'amuser
et faire un projet.
Musique dynamique
...
-Allô ?
On fait quoi ?
-Tu m'entends ?
-OK. Est-ce qu'on est prêts ?
-OUI.
-Bonjour. On est bien
à Mon Paris FM,
la webradio Paris 13e.
Je suis avec les élèves
de Château des Rentiers.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler
du sport en équipe.
Qui peut me donner
un sport d'équipe ?
Vas-y.
-Le foot.
-Le foot, voilà.
Vas-y, dis-moi.
-Le basket.
-Bonjour, Willy ! Qu'est-ce que
vous faites dans cet atelier ?
-Dans cet atelier,
on fait la webradio.
L'objectif de cet atelier,
c'est de les faire parler
de la vie quotidienne à l'école,
et un peu sur ce qu'ils connaissent,
apprendre la discipline
à la radio,
parce que c'est chacun son tour.
Ca, en général, les enfants,
c'est compliqué,
mais quand on leur explique bien,
on arrive à faire
des bonnes émissions assez jolies.
Les enfants rient.
...
-Vous avez tous remarqué
la différence
avec les films des frères Lumière,
c'est qu'il y a un début,
un milieu et une fin.
Tout le monde a repéré le début ?
C'est jusqu'à quand,
Armand ?
-Jusqu'au...
Jusqu'au tonneau !
-Très bien !
On est encore dans le registre
du drôle, du comique,
comme Charlie Chaplin
et les frères Lumière.
-Je me permets de vous couper
dans cet atelier cinéma.
Quel est l'objectif
de cet atelier ?
-L'idée, c'est qu'à la fin
du trimestre,
on puisse fabriquer un petit film
qu'ils puissent toucher
avec leurs mains.
-Ca vous plaît,
les enfants ?
-OUI !
-Tant mieux.
On va vous laisser continuer.
-Au revoir !
Musique douce
-Xuan, t'en as combien ?
-J'en ai 14 moins 1.
-T'as fait l'appel ?
-Oui.
...
-Vous venez voir
l'animateur, l'animatrice,
à chaque fois
que vous avez fini un exercice ?
-OUI.
-Ou quand on n'y arrive pas.
-Pour être corrigés,
ou quand on a besoin d'aide.
-D'accord, et l'objectif,
c'est que les devoirs
soient faits
à la fin de l'étude ?
-OUI.
-Alors, elle est bonne,
l'opération ?
-Oui, c'est parfait.
Voilà.
Ensuite ?
-Donc là, la journée
est quasiment terminée ?
-Il est presque 18h,
c'est l'heure de la sortie.
Musique dynamique
...
Musique douce
-Quand l'école fait son cinéma.
Le Réseau Canopé
a choisi de s'intéresser
au 7e art et à la façon
dont il est entré dans les écoles.
Pour une fois, ce n'est pas
sous Jules Ferry que cela commence.
-Combien de temps a-t-il fallu
pour que l'école
rencontre le cinéma ?
-5 minutes ?
-Pas tout à fait,
mais nous n'avons que 180 secondes
pour répondre.
Nous abuserons donc de figures
connues des cinéphiles,
l'ellipse,
l'accéléré et le faux raccord.
-On fait un essai ?
-1895.
Quand les ouvriers
et les ouvrières
sortent des usines Lumière,
ce n'est pas pour aller
au cinéma ou à la Sorbonne.
La Sorbonne,
où le 16 avril 1895 a lieu
la seconde projection privée
de l'histoire du cinématographe.
Cette Sorbonne n'est alors
qu'un décor.
Dans la salle, pas d'étudiants,
mais des savants.
Années 20 : les ciné-clubs
prennent leur essor.
Ils seront essentiels
dans l'éducation des spectateurs.
Certains deviendront
de grands cinéastes.
Après la projection,
les discussions sont animées.
-Si je dis que moi, ce film
me fait l'effet d'une tapisserie,
ce ne sera pas vrai
pour tout le monde.
-Accord, désaccord,
ce qui ne fait pas discussion
dans ces clubs,
c'est que le cinéma est un art.
Le dire ne suffit pas toujours.
On est là
pour apprendre à regarder.
Années 30.
De Jean Zay,
les cinéphiles retiennent
qu'il a créé
le festival de Cannes.
Mais c'est aussi le premier
à vouloir mettre le projecteur
au milieu de la classe.
L'ancêtre du Centre national
de documentation pédagogique,
CNDP, naît en 1932.
Les images projetées
intéressent les pédagogues.
Elles sont jugées utiles
pour observer les libellules,
les racines carrées,
et même la beauté du paysage.
-Cette beauté est difficile.
Difficile à découvrir,
à admettre.
Elle est paradoxale.
-1984.
Ca y est, c'est fait.
Les caméras passent la porte
des établissements scolaires.
L'option cinéma et audiovisuel
voit le jour.
Elle figurera
aux épreuves du bac en 1986.
Fin 80.
Les ministères de l'Education,
de la Culture et le Centre national
de la cinématographie
préparent un gros coup.
Avec le futur "Ma classe au cinéma",
2 millions d'élèves,
de la maternelle
au lycée,
vont dans les salles.
Antoine Doinel
n'en reviendrait pas.
En 2001, le plan Lang/Tasca
renforce la présence du 7e art
au sein des établissements.
Le CNDP, lui, édite de nombreuses
ressources pour les enseignants.
Le cinéma à l'école
se réaffirme encore.
On passe d'un cours de maths
à une projection
de "Psychose", on fait de l'histoire
en analysant "Les 400 coups".
Les spectateurs de demain
aiguisent leur regard
et acquièrent compétences
et savoirs.
Ils prennent en main les outils
et découvrent la cinématographie
du monde entier.
Plus que jamais,
les images sont partout.
Elles se font transportables.
Les poches en sont pleines.
Les yeux en débordent.
Il est donc toujours plus urgent
de faire prendre conscience
aux élèves
ce qu'un travelling
peut vouloir dire,
ce qu'un son peut évoquer
et ce qu'un raccord
peut engendrer,
mais sans leur faire oublier
qu'au cinéma,
on peut toujours rêver.
Musique douce
...
-La prochaine émission
sera sur la caméra.
Musique intrigante
...
-L'émission est terminée
mais nous, on se retrouve
très vite sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...